we have just review from Georgia Tech
but she's gonna tell us our course if
you don't have for working fine thank
you so I'll tell you about positive
hyperbola Ferrari stem first I know you
are noticed but let us recall the
definition of Agrawal polynomial is
stable polynomials and then we'll see
how they generalize to varieties so less
we call a homogeneous polynomial all
equal respect to a point G with respect
to a point polynomial and variable
respect to a point in R to the N if
every line meet like my surface my my
equals zero only at RIA points so that's
the definition of a type of Allah
variety and we say that F is stable if
you take any route X is equal to 0
implies that the imaginary part is not a
nice space I so there's a relationship
between this maybe if you have never
seen is not obvious but it's know how to
prove that the homogeneous polynomial is
[Music]
stable if and only if it is hyperbolic
with respect to you every point in the
positive thank you every
right and then so yeah so yes then
there's a larger part time today I mean
this week and then um so especially in
rice India stuff yesterday we saw that
the stable polynomials have a nice may
try to structure so we saw that new to
polytopes
stable polynomials
Cynthia column generalize Juanita Hedra
or I'm natural comedy accident also
generalized on your horizon
okay so this was proven for the Marty
Alpha homogeneous varieties by then it
was proven more generally all right
so now so this is a there's a story that
a lot of people here are familiar with
so now we're gonna move on to variety so
varieties are algebraic steps I wore
today I'll assume that all the varieties
are equi dimensional men and all the
components have the same dimension I
would not assume that they are
irreducible or reduced so these are
breasts that defined by polynomial
equations okay so nothing so now what is
the hyperbolic / re so this was defined
by arm
so they define that a Ferrari projective
Irani
server Rd X and V ay minus one is
hyperbolic with respect to something so
with respect to I should say a variety
of core dimensions see okay so today's
talk see it's going to be the core
dimension of the variety well respect to
our linear subspace of dimension C minus
1 right so for this hyper surface case
right Co dimension is 1 C is 1 so we're
talking about hyperbole of a respect to
a point right so right now we're talking
about hyperbole we respect to a linear
subspace or column I should say minus 1
if let me give it a name in linear
subspace V okay so if for every linear
subspace every linear you that contains
me of Galatian see you intercept X only
a real point
yeah so you have on yes I know how to
draw some picture we think this is this
is wrong [ __ ] okay this India was wrong
yesterday and then if you have a say a
curve in space right this let's go to
mention too so that if it is to be
hyperbola will respect to you know align
right it means that if you pass any
plane that contains a life but needs to
meet the curve only of your box right so
they are shamanism in akov they looked
at you know determine natural
representation very reasonable lives
that time determine a representation of
these varieties I connect them through
light the child forms indeterminate
representations then so this is the
hyperbolic picture and you can also sort
of our look at the analog this this
condition right for varieties so we say
that over re so in this case we know
will assume imaginary let's say where
are you at in see any yes we can call it
stable than just to avoid confusion with
our stable we're going to call this are
positively hyperbolic
what stable is used a lot already in
algebraic geometry so positively
hyperbolic if if you look at the points
and I look at the imaginary point there
should not be any positive linear spaces
if X a variety the imaginary part is not
in any positive linear space of
dimension see X sub 0
zero is allowed to be in my product
yes oh okay a positive linear space is a
linear space ah it's a row span of a
matrix whose maximum minors are all
positive there's a positive bigger space
it is also what people call you know
those linear space are in the positive
grass money in other words all the polka
corners are strictly positive so that's
the definition and then ah and then
these two definitions are the same so
this was evident that Ferrari projective
arari quasi-projective prime it's
positively hyperbolic in this sense on
this definition if and only if it is
hyperbolic with respect to every
positive linear space so it's not a
total logical but there is something to
prove that okay right so these two
definitions are equivalent
so the main questions that we want to
look at is what is the analog of these
statements right so what is ah yeah so
what is the other I'll then may try to
structure to these arise have any well
okay so this day of all polynomials are
already ignores for fixing or for oh yes
again for fixing that's right so of
collimation see thank you this hyperbola
respect to every positive linear space
yeah in brass money and stay dimensional
yes that's right so yeah so okay High
Pass open it's a little bit cheating
these are example
so come on of ensign showed that if for
any linear space space the reciprocal
Union space
no it's a rule notation reciprocal in
your space so you take the you take the
point you take all the points where non
zero Corning's and then you take the
reciprocal or each coordinate this is a
linear space ah so this is an example of
example of this no okay anyway let's
proceed programming your space is
hyperbolic we respect you also gonna
compliment about this is one nice family
of examples they also give some explicit
formulas for the Chow points
how about cuts yeah so um i yes i
believe some of it some vinegar shows
that all reoccur cyberbully with respect
to something no okay
I mean it's a lot of curse maybe I do
know they all cause but a lot of curves
fiber ball they were respective
certainly also happy and has embedding
them okay okay everything that's of
dividing time something by the resonant
Betty okay yes so they are they are yeah
a lot less number of cuts so well okay I
admit that we we don't have a lot of
examples so one of the questions maybe
and discussions at the end of the talk
can be how can we come up with more
examples and constructions of hyperbolic
right good and if you start with the
right type of linear space-time user
super cool ones are stable or positively
hyperbolic yeah that's right so if you
start out with
okay yeah I'll be good right so we want
to get a I mean maybe it's what you said
earlier in the hyperbolic in for
polynomials case somehow the determinant
our class is the very natural thing
right these are something similarity are
right so that is this place called yes
the distance was very reasonable lives
sick determinants are representations
very reasonable okay okay so we want to
yeah so this is our anyway so right this
is the it's the main question that we
you know we want to study right and then
yeah so the answer is gonna be yes
otherwise I would have we given this
talk all right yeah but then we have to
you know see like why do we go look for
this may try to structure right what is
the Newton polytope right so before we
get there you know we you might ask what
is the Newton polytope
so to me tropical Ferrari is tropical
ization natural it's a generalization on
Newton volatile so which I will
introduce a bit later and then from this
tropical ization if you insist on
getting a polytope you can also get a
polytope call it Voyager which is a
projection of the nutribullet over this
child so we'll see that both the
tropical addition and the chocolate Oh
have made try to structure okay so now
let's I'll show you how we can get a
handle on these are positively
hyperbolic varieties so
[Music]
so in this case maybe this is I want to
draw a picture of the Cynthia this is
like one of the exercises the Cynthia
sign yesterday above stable Polly about
if you have I you know if you have a
stable binomial right so if you have a
stable I know me or something like
actually of X to the beta so they write
what is zero right if this is stable
then I saw from yesterday is all that
right alpha minus beta right has to be
you know looks like either plus or minus
e I or minus T so one way to see this
for for the case one you only have two
variable yes um like this and so you
look um you have two variables we have a
one one polynomial then you can look at
is on this imaginary part imaginary part
of the points or you can also look at
the face of the complex numbers so the
imaginary projection or the what is
called a KO amoeba
good
we're gonna the complex face imaginary
points that satisfy equation like this
right so if you have only like variables
x and y right and then you have
imaginary part can now be positive right
both positive so that means the business
out and if you have like real you know
polynomials right so they come in
complex conjugate pairs yeah so you know
this is also out and then if you have
something if you look at solution sets
of these right so imaginary parts are is
going to be a line in here because these
these kind of conditions on their
exponents I translate to the linear
conditions on the other face so Amissah
you're gonna have a you can have a line
in here but a line can now go through
this open square right here and open
square right here by the only way it can
be is to be like this
or it can be like this
so cuz they wrap around weird because
they wrap around yeah that's right so it
cannot be like yeah so right it cannot
be like this guy's gonna be full that
that's not typically for me but yeah
this is very special because it's like
binomial tourists so yeah so we want
some some some nice pictures like this
is how we started like drawing this
picture that's really upstairs right
here one or we were on here in fall of
2017 one philippi and I wear Emma's
alright so so we discover the following
following characterizations are
positively hyperbola Ferraris using sign
variations where do you say some
examples and now we realize that these
points and positive linear spaces have
certain sign patterns so it turns out
that this has been known since nineteen
fifties okay so yeah so the question is
how do we how do we characterize coins
right in the in a positive linear spaces
so question is right how do we know
point a part in right it's in a positive
in your space
so this isn't there I'm from 1950 and
then so we will use a reformulation by
Stephen curve who was a grad student
yang Butler from 2015
so they said the four for a point let's
say X in RN and fixie right so X yes and
a positive linear space
religion see if and only if a sign
variation which I'll define the sign
variation in C has to be no sin x has to
be less than C okay so the first time
variation is like this so if you look at
Val bar of all other some a vector so in
this case I'm just going to make up
something right 2 negative 3 0 0
negative 4 like that ok so then you look
at how many times the sign changes the Y
is e 0 you want to choose the signs for
the zeros to maximize the number of sign
changes so if you have these two so
right here I have one sign change right
and I have one sign change and here no
matter how you choose you can have at
most two sign changes so that means that
the maximum normal sign changes
so this is a so this is very quick way
to tell whether you know a point is in
some positive in your space dimension so
this tells us
okay so from you know we have this a
useful useful characterisations or
positively hyperbolic Ferraris
I wish follow immediately from here is
the axis positively hyperbolic if and
only if every point in my Ferrari the
sign variation of the imaginary part it
has to be at least
this allows us to prove various things
about be positive we have Nepali
varieties so one one thing that you can
ask is which also this shows that you
know you can take in a reciprocal right
is good because when you take a
reciprocal of a complex number right you
you flip you flip the sign okay so if
you take a reciprocal and also stick in
a negative sign you doesn't change the
time variation so this is an operation
that you can do here by Murari you can
do a reciprocal of any coordinate and
flip the sign you get another positively
hyperbolic variety okay so Anna how
about your usual linear spaces we say
the linear space it's positively
hyperbolic if and only if it is defined
over reals
a priori you know in the definition you
don't have to even be defined by real
but in this case it has to be defined
over real and it's orthogonal complement
so this is a generalization of the fact
that a hyperplane is positively
hyperbolic no sorry a hyperplane is
stable if its normal vector is
non-negative so this you can prove uses
sign variation and then so this told us
right so so yeah so a corollary and that
you know if you have such a linear space
race to the the mate right so the maitre
of a linear space is like this if you
have a linear space you write it as a
row space of a matrix and then you look
at the linear independence on the
columns of that matrix so the you know
the independence among the column
doesn't depend on your choice of
generator so so there's a matrix so the
maitre of a positively hyperbolic
Linnea space is a positive it was a
treat was a try is a is a matrix all of
whose maximum miners are no negative so
they suppository it's not obvious so we
need a theorem so this follow from a
theorem of a Dilla recon Williams
because that shows that the dual of a
positron is a pilot right okay so
because because of this offer gonna
complement right because um yeah so in
general you know L pub is non-negative
does that mean that is not negative but
LS um you know but L has a mate right
and alpha has a mate right right so if
alpha is no negative may try of alpha is
a positron by this theorem may try of L
is about the time it doesn't man that
Alice no negative
there is some content to this kirari
it's not so trivial and then we also
have a another nice corollary algebraic
meat right a positively hyperbola
Ferrari is a father Trey irreducible so
every irreducible váradi has a has a
matrix so it is a metric whose ground
set is the set of Corning's so it's a
irreducible Ferrari with an embedding
okay in some affine space with some
chosen coordinates so you got a may try
whose rank function is the dimension of
the projection this is called the
algebra image right and then so it turns
out that as a brain may try of a
positive above Oliver also how these
positive eye structure that is because
if you have a algebraic may try of a
Ferrari who is the same as your it may
try of attendance this tangent space as
a general point and then as we talked
about right now like two days ago that
if a VAR re is positively hyperbolic
then it's tangent spaces also positively
hyperbolic therefore from this lemma we
know that so we already see that is
positive I'm a believer re has so nice
combined Horrocks happening
now we want to we want to move on to our
tribe organization to be able to stay
calm in there sorry are you varieties
like it does not light in any hyperplane
doesn't mean that naturally I'm told
also independence outside uh no it does
not it's not about whether I doesn't lie
in a hyperplane I mean can you give an
example so no one trivial may try like
you mean like so you're saying that
that's all I know
like okay we're talking about yeah
dimension on the projection yes so if
you look at yeah so right so it's
something that is defined by you know X
square plus y square one
right so so on the XYZ space right so
the base these are right X Z and Y Z
because you know yeah right projection
onto XZ corner is two-dimensional
projection onto Y Z coordinate
two-dimensional a projection onto XY
corner is one dimensional so it's not a
race
any other questions so now yeah let me
introduce tropical tropical ization a
little bit
okay so tropical ization as a process
that takes process that takes Ferrari X
and then let's say in it like you know
Taurus C star to the end and then they
give you a polyhedral complex we can't
drop X doesn't have to be C it can be
some other feel it's too easy today
so this is a right so you start out with
any variety and then you start it out
you end up with a polyhedral complex of
same dimension as X so so the definition
is that this is equal to one definition
so the set of all the way factors such
that the initial ideal so you look at
the idea of the other polynomials of
varnish on X and then you look at all
the initial forms with respect to my
wave vector as the ways in they are
defined yesterday right and then you
look at the idea generated by those and
that does not contain a monomial all
right so this shows that this is
something related to grown on basis and
is computable maybe a little more comes
natural definition maybe you you look at
your all the points now you take your
variety and then you extend is feel - R
- a - a feel with on non trivial no
Archimedean valuations like the weight
like a poison series right so if you
started out with you know complex number
you go to a complex with the series and
then you take the same equations that
define it and you look at your poison
series points and then you look at the
valuations of those points it's a nice
another definition so a priori is not
obvious that you know how you might
compute these things it's a little more
conceptual you can also think of this as
if you prefer this is also is choco
quality gloss
and some nice toric right right so this
is some so troubled organization is a
process right that takes over re into a
political complex and if you start out
with so yes some the special cases that
one can keep in mind so if you start out
with a start-up where hypersurface
so face F equal to zero example right so
if you have a hypersurface of equal to
zero for example just to be concrete
I make example 1 plus X plus y plus y
square go to 0 for example polytope y
squared and I using this definition
about the monomial right so I'm looking
at you know which arm so I'll be using
the min so I'm looking at which what are
the possible initial forms are okay so
if my weight is along this line right so
my initial form is going to be 1 plus y
if my weight is over here my initial
form is one right here it's going to be
Y squared is X so if my weight is
straight up so this definition sir I
only need to take though I want to take
the weight where the initial idea does
not contain a monomial so that means
that I'm not allowed to take these open
regions I semi-tropical Ferrari consists
of just three race I so from here you
can see that I can recover right this
Newton call it out from my tropical
variety so in that sense recover Ari is
a generalization of the Newton politics
so to be more correct I even attach
numbers to these race to to tell me how
long the corresponding edges are then I
can I can't recover the polytope so then
another case is one where my Ferrari is
a linear space
the in this case the tropical Ferrari of
a linear space is or something called a
badminton so this is a representation of
a mate right
so Backman fan so tropical ization what
tropical isolation sees about a linear
space this is may try is may try and
only the metric and then so another if
the more s 1x is at or over re given by
a monomial parameterization so let's get
monomial parameterization and then I I
take the exponents of the monomial and I
put them as columns of a matrix a then
in that case the Tropico Ferrari of X is
the row space of it so this fact is more
easily seen by this on this valuation
definition because valuation interacts
well with monomial parameterization so
valuation of a product is the sum of the
valuation
so so these are interesting examples of
tropical vacations to keep in mind so in
any case right the point is the tropical
ization of a it's a procedure that takes
a Ferrari and it gives you a polyhedral
complex that encodes combinatorial
invariants of your variety yes okay so
if X is positively hyperbolic then any
maximal cone it's tropical ization is
any and is there a linear space in the
direction of Messimer cone that's right
me okay
hey max Macomb is spanned by 0 1 minus 1
vectors right whose supports are
disjoint and non-crossing so I'll show
you why I'm in like non-crossing for
example if I have a saying yes 0 1 minus
1 backed up I mean so the rows are 0 1
minus 1 vector who suppose are disjoint
but if you look at the so I have my
coordinates right 1 2 3 4 the first one
has support 1 and 3 and second one is
support 2 and 4 okay so the supports are
crossing so this is not allowed
so that counts them I these two rings is
not allowed to be in the maximum account
of a positive attack upon it so I don't
cross instructure and yeah so and then
what you can see right because you know
the yeah there's some I this kind of
vector that means if you look at if you
look at the you look at the relationship
between any columns right so they are
either you know they can be 0 you can
have 0 comments or you can have columns
are off by negative sign or columns the
other thing that's the only thing you're
not right so that Minster in other words
right in particular right there cut out
by these cones or the linear span of
these comes right they are cut out by
equations of the form X I equals 0 or X
I is equal to plus or minus XJ right so
these are the directions that you have
seen from Cynthia's talk yesterday and
then if you have homogeneous
so if it is defined my homogeneous idea
you know there was a projective Ferrari
then you're not allowed to have negative
one because no homogeneous right you're
not allowed to have x equals zero and
then you're not allowed to have negative
one over you okay so they have to be cut
out by X I equal to XJ right so these
aren't also you know in other words this
Mitrovica variety has to be a sub fan of
the penet oh hey terrific the type a
great original thing so this is yeah so
this gave us a happy answer to you know
art is that a matrix structure so happy
that this is a sense to be a good metric
structure constant coefficient case what
if you take same thing yeah same thing
because this is a local statement yeah
the same thing so it doesn't in that
case you know we're talking about the
direction right the direction of the
Maxima cone have these structure you
take any maximal cone in your tropical
variety even if it is not a fan right
even it's like tiny little piece the
maximal cell shutting myself
okay not a call memory I should say
maximum face
yeah so yeah so so this in fact
generalize right you gather this resort
by looking at what happened in the
hypersurface case because if you stand
in this example right this example it
was small but you can see that you know
the maximal faces right of the Tropic
over re orthogonal to edges of the
newton per liter so in the hypersurface
case we've seen that right so maxima
faces have to be cut out by X I go to XJ
now Mesa in the Newton polytope right
the you know the edges that show up in
the Newton pollito has to be in the
direction yeah - EJ so that means that
the Newton polytopes right are you know
of these yeah - EJ directions or if you
allowed no homogeneous then you have
also Jesse I yeah and also also works
with evaluation so yes right now was
asking it right so you can in that case
you know instead of a Newton pollito if
the coefficients of the valuation you
look at the subdivision of the Newton
pollito induced by the valuation and
then using the same theorem you see that
all the edges in a subdivision has to be
in this VI minus et directions so this
we recover this and the complexity
result of rounding yeah and another
consequence of this theorem is that if
you apply to are to bergman fence so if
X is a linear space X is a linear space
that is Cho and then combined with my
llama about
the level of our linear spaces right
corresponding to the positrons
awesome Karara Reese so this you can
prove from here so another corollary is
that a Bergman fan has a choice non
cross and maximum faces
so in other words you take a back my fan
of apposite right and then you look at a
maximum face and then it has to if you
look at the supports they are
non-crossing
and in fact we also show that this is if
and only if so this completely
characterizes the positives so if you
have a bagman fan whose Maxima face are
not crossing then it has to be up on the
tray and also another corollary is that
a child Polito a projective possibly
hyperbola ferrari laferrari is a
generalized parameter so Alex think 10
years ago has a result about how you can
construct a polytope from the tropical
Ferrari and we can just apply it to this
theorem and it tells us that the child
polytopes are also have edges
interaction yeah - AJ so I just again
may try to write so this thing is
alright so I just talked through them
yeah so the proof idea is you we first
show that this positive hyperbola story
is preserve undertaken initiated
generations and then you look at
initially generation at a point in a
Maxima count of the traffic over re and
then the irreducible components in
nature' X are Tory varieties and then we
have to prove the theorem for the Tory
variety using some variations this is
the idea of the proof and then you can
ask about how about the convex you know
if I have a whole hero complex that
looks like a tropical Ferrari and the
satisfies this nice condition does they
actually come from a positive hyperbola
variety
all of us
okay visit my eraser
right so in other words this a
realizability question right so
something that looks you know a tropical
variety that looks nice is it realizable
in this nice way so in general I just
know in the hypersurface case for
example so it actually hypersurface case
we don't get anything new because we
already know that they you know the
edges are in these directions and then
these non cross name doesn't give us
anything new because everything is that
non-trivial
I mean trivially non-crossing I mean
there's no presence so yeah so
hypersurface case you know that the same
example about Brandon's example about
this far no metric polytope so the hyper
tropical hyper surface of the fondo
metropolitan it's it doesn't it's not a
Nippon polytope of a stable polynomial
I'm sorry the same same counter example
or I for the non constant coefficient
curve aspire superabundant
curves also satisfy this condition but
it's not realizable these are not
realizable
as you know tropical ization of anything
so they cannot be realizable as tropical
ization or hyperbolic curves so but we
proved that it is yes in a number of
cases so it is yes for for bagmen fins
sort of all kind of follow from what I
said already so if you have a bagman fan
it's not so if it just realize the boy
if it come from all right positively
hyperbolic Ferraris then it's all zebra
maitre has to be a positron the other
hand yeah all posit rice I realize the
ball because look at the compliments so
so this bag my fantasy is follow from
thanks I have said using an algebra
teacher and also yes for usual linear
spaces spaces so tropical is Asians are
Tori varieties
so if a usual in your space or tropical
Toliver already has these conditions so
it has to come from a positively we have
the bottom one and then it is also yes
for projective curves projective
constant coefficient okay so these are
these are tropical curves there are
actually a bunch of race it doesn't have
like by nice segments that's right miss
Russell so in this case we give explicit
parameterization so if you give me one
of these curves that satisfy these
conditions then I can give you a
parameterization or possibly had one
already
okay so I'll stop yeah what about
Laurentian varieties yeah I don't know
yeah good question we we've talked about
it briefly but we don't know what that
means whatever they are they're topic
whatever nation
[Music]
I can ask questions how do we check
these things I don't know if someone
gave me a variety I don't know if it is
possibility hyperbolic or you could have
had a Piper Bollywood effect or give
around in your space I do not attack
that how do we generate examples how do
we related to value depositories maybe
or real traffic realizations ask one
more question so the physicists like the
amplitude row you thought about
connections to the amplitude yeah we
have talked to Laura Williams and you
know we have I mean maybe but we have no
funny concrete I mean it feels like it
feels like it should be related and we
have had at least one composition about
it but yeah I think that's why Steven
cartload was looking at the sign berry
that's how we learn about sign variation
you know we did examples and we found
the sign variation that were like way
Lauren talked about this you know two
weeks ago so the ball isn't for studying
hyperbolic and stable polynomials in
combinatory exists that it gives rise to
all these inequalities like law
concavity Alexandre Frankel inequality
permaculture you know all that can you
see it any any inequalities yeah yeah
that's a good question I don't know not
yet over
yeah
I can't resist so there are many papers
about the positive cross Manya you're
gonna write one about positive yeah yeah
so I think yeah this is pretty new and I
think they have like yeah the point is
that they have nice convert area
structure and hopefully is useful to
this community or other people and so
like in the blank for at robot for
animals up to a linear transformation
they can be made stable right for for
hyperbolic varieties does it through
this experience okay I think you don't
happen every day yeah
yeah it's not clear yeah so the question
is how come we always yeah change
coordinator and get a positively
hyperbolic like some of it is gonna do
show that there's a little a publicity
region in the grass money and if you
start with I miss all right it's convex
yeah I mean you know some fairly weak
way it's convex yeah there's the notion
of a hyperbola city region here is a
component of the child form in the grass
money so and then but you need to do
some transformation that you know puts
the positive for a snotty and excited
set rejection I don't know how to do
that yeah it's not clear yeah so we did
we do have a bunch of our your
operations are preserve this positive
hyperbola city but but change a corner
is the hard one or linear transformation
so much more than we think
Josephine
[Applause]